web at simon says dot com
now on encore book notes nicholas
kristoff and cheryl wooden co-authors of
china wakes the struggle for the soul of
a rising power this talk from 1994 lasts
about an hour
nicholas christoph co-author of china
wakes who was harold sue
harold was a young man who his family
believed very much in the communist
party and he was the youngest foreign
ministry diplomat when he first joined
the foreign ministry after the communist
revolution
he became the english interpreter for
joe and lai and
occasionally for mao zedong himself
you know he was a real star and somebody
who would have risen i think perhaps all
the way
perhaps to be foreign minister
then he made the mistake on a trip to uh
on a trip to india with foreign minister
joe and lai
of buying some shirts
and uh going to a movie
with
with foreign ministry funds and he
thought well i'll just pay them back
um
and then he also made the mistake of
telling the indian government joe and
lai's preference is for food and color
to make
joe and liz stay a little more
comfortable well the result was when he
got back to beijing he was reported he
was sent off to prison for 10 years
his career destroyed
and after he was finally released from
prison
he was sent off uh to a village in
remote part of china to work for 10 more
years throughout
throughout much of the cultural
revolution
and
finally in i believe 1978 china
desperately needed english teachers and
here they had you know somebody who had
been one of the great english speakers
in the country and an interpreter for
mao and they found him in this remote
village and brought him back
but i remember maybe the most
poignant thing was when he was telling
me the story he had talked about his
mother and how
how he had begged the authorities not to
tell
his mother about his arrest and about
his imprisonment
and
at the very end i thought back about her
and i said well you know so did they
tell your mother
and he said uh that they had and i said
well you know what happened and he said
uh that she was
so horrified by his by his fall uh that
she had committed suicide and that he
had his father had written him a note in
prison to tell him about this now how
did you meet him
he was uh a friend of ours this book is
really about our friends in china and to
a great extent and he was one of our
friends uh in china and somebody we
became very close to and you know i
always wondered because
you know if he had become a foreign
minister that this was a time when the
foreign minister was denouncing us was
calling us in for these struggle
sessions with them and i always wondered
you know if he had become a foreign
minister would he be announcing us as
well and that
you know now he's okay he's living
freely in beijing and
in some ways i kind of figured that this
whole brutal experience that he went
through in some sense freed him now you
mentioned joe and lie who was he
joe and i was the prime minister and
foreign minister and
effectively the number two to mao zedong
and when did harold sue work for him
uh throughout the
essentially the mid 50s until his
imprisonment
in
1957
and you wrote this book with your wife
and you did
each you know a chapter and then she did
another chapter uh how did you decide
which chapters to write
we uh
uh part of it was that we wanted to
preserve our own voices and there were
some things that i felt more passionate
about some things that cheryl felt more
passionate about uh
and part of it was simply uh arbitrary
and cheryl for example was particularly
interested in the plight of chinese
women and she had her own experiences as
a as a chinese-american woman and so
that was a natural for her um
i had been on tiananmen square when the
troops opened fire so a chapter about
tiananmen in history was more of a
natural for me you speak chinese i speak
chinese where did you learn it
mostly in taiwan but also just a
function of living in china for five
years and
spending you know
just about every night with chinese
friends
gossiping about this about that about
their likes and dislikes
cheryl wudun where's the name come from
oh well that's um
i found that when i went to china on my
first visit
i remember i am a third generation
chinese-american and uh grew up in new
york city and had no interest in going
to the countryside
but uh nicholas kristof actually
encouraged me to go
and i remember driving down that path
we were driving through the scattered
rice paddies it was
a land away from what i had grown up uh
what i had grown up in and we got to the
small little village at the edge of a at
the edge of a little lake and uh there i
was standing in in the in the village
and i was
must have been two feet taller than
almost everybody else there and the
women there were all gray-haired and the
children were tiny tiny little kids and
and i thought this is the village where
my father's father was from
and
i didn't think that i had any relatives
there i was sure i i had nothing in
common with these people and as i talked
and talked and i told them who my
grandfather was they said yes yes
i am your distant cousin a woman said as
she stepped forward and i was shocked
she had a different last name of course
her in cantonese her last name was i'm
going to pronounce it's going to sound
awkward
and
it was from there that i found the story
of how my my name had had become wooden
what had happened was that my
grandfather had
bought some papers which was common in
those days to go overseas to to the us
and the papers had the same last name
because in cantonese my name the first
part of my name is
and he got to ellis island and he said
well my name
is now that just really means like uncle
sam
and they didn't hear the
they had no idea what it was they didn't
know what to do with it so they just
heard the done they said oh your name is
done
so my grandfather for the longest time
was william dunn
and finally after getting all these
phone calls
people calling up and saying are you
done and then hang up he decided well
he's going to take the manner
pronunciation of his name and call it
wu-dun so that's how i'm done
now you found out something about your
grandfather didn't particularly care for
yes i did it was um rather shocking
while i was there i discovered that he
had had a another wife a wife before my
grandmother and that in fact they had
both gone to the u.s
the first wife and my grandfather and
she bore him two daughters but no son
and so they went back to china and on
that trip he decided to leave her there
she wasn't going to be able to bear him
any more sons he thought and so he took
another wife
and brought her back to the u.s
and
had three children including my father
so it was a very rude awakening to
discover that he had essentially
abandoned his uh first wife he never saw
her again and she uh
stayed there until she died in the 1960s
how did you two meet
we were in los angeles um i was working
for the new york times cheryl for the
wall street journal
and um so we started this incredibly
complicated courtship whereby we
couldn't really talk about what either
of us was doing
um and you know
i would
leave messages uh with cheryl at the
wall street journal just as nick
why did what was the attraction
what was the attraction to him yes oh
well of course and he was this famous
reporter
i remember in the bureau and see he was
the only business reporter uh for the
new york times in la and our bureau at
the wall street journal had uh nine
people there they were all covering the
same exact events that he was the same
all the same news news events and
quite often uh we would open the paper
in the morning and they just that
kristoff how did he do this
and all five of them would be gathered
around the newspaper article trying to
figure out how did this one guy beat
nine other reporters in the bureau
now
when did you marry
in 1988 just as we were leaving to china
china was our honeymoon
your honeymoon so to speak for the first
seven months we're just a wonderful
wonderful time you know we arrived in
november 1988
literally fresh from our honeymoon just
after getting married and that was just
the most open time in in china's history
we could go off and see friends we
we would have a lunch with just about
anybody we wanted to
one time we drove a friend back into
jungnan hai the chinese leadership
compound which is like the kremlin
and you know it was all okay then
until
tiananmen then what
then
overnight everything changed um
i mean
we were changed i
it is an absolutely transforming
experience when you're on tiananmen
square and you
are being shot at by these troops and
you're seeing kids around you killed
but more i mean that was one night or
the killing went on a few days but
what was in sense more traumatic almost
for us was
just the the the way the whole
repressive apparatus clamped down on us
and
you know we were followed every time
we'd leave our apartment we'd have these
government goons behind us uh you know a
couple of cars motorcycles trying to
figure out our sources
and
uh you know our phones were tapped the
rooms were bugged
office was broken into we were called
into the foreign ministry regularly to
be denounced it was
the worst thing was this fear of getting
your friends in trouble when did you
leave china permanently 1993 at the end
of 1993. and this book that you've
written did you spend time doing only
that uh yes we did we spent a few months
while we were still in china
working just on the book i mean the book
is a culmination of our five years there
uh we heard hundreds of stories from all
the people we met and we we've had
many many different experiences and we
wanted china to come alive to americans
we wanted we wanted to tell the stories
of the many different chinese that we
met
the minister that you danced with yes
that was interesting in fact nick and i
had a very good partnership because
there were times when the chinese wanted
to meet a foreigner and they call
they call him a big-nosed foreigner
big-nosed american i provide the news
for instance when he went to beijing
university and he would do interviews
students knew that he wasn't a spy but
me they made they weren't always so sure
but there were other times when
they didn't want to speak to a foreigner
they didn't want to get caught
with a foreigner and so i could slip
into their homes and learn their secrets
i remember one time
i was researching the topic of sexual
harassment and the status of women and i
found myself at a a dinner dance party
and a cabinet minister asked me to dance
he apparently thought that i was a local
secretary or something and as soon as we
got out onto the dance floor he tried to
force himself upon me
i was shocked
but it gave me tremendous insight into
the status of women into how women are
treated and how cabinet ministers look
upon them as perks
certainly a non-chinese wouldn't have
been able to have that kind of
experience what kind of an accent do you
have uh it's very interesting the nice
thing about china is that it's such a
vast country that uh full of so many
different dialects that if you're in the
north people will say oh you have a
southern accent if you're in the south
people say oh you have a western accent
it was very very useful
you went on a trip once
and um
as a tourist while you're a reporter why
did you have to do that because if
you're a reporter then every time you
leave beijing and go somewhere else in
china you have to go through officially
you have to go through the foreign
ministry and get their permission what
that means is then well a they may deny
you the right to go but secondly even if
they give you the right they're going to
meet you at the airport take you to a
hotel often they stay in the hotel room
right next to yours they book up every
moment of your time and they arrange
all of your interviews and it really
becomes a farce you know you
they i remember once asking to to
interview some poor peasants and you
know so i go to a poor part of china
they take me off into the countryside
they're about you know 10 officials
trailing me
and uh we pull in i knew there was a
problem when we this poor peasant so to
speak lived in this you know huge
courtyard uh he had a motorcycle and you
know a beautiful place um
it and so cheryl and i increasingly
decided that
if we were gonna convey
the reality of china we pretty much had
to break the rules and we had to go out
into the countryside without these
people following us
and
so that's why we did it where did you go
on this one particular trip i remember
reading you said you went down 11
flights of stairs to from your apartment
to the security people right they were
uh
there were cameras in the elevators and
so i didn't want to tip them off and of
course that meant also you know i
couldn't
arrange any of the tickets on the
telephone which was bugged or uh you
know or in the apartment or in the
office but i got them separately and
then
went down
the stairs uh hid as the car left the
compound because they were cameras and
guards at the gate of the compound where
we were forced to live
and
went off to the airport and
i went to xinjiang on that trip it's
like a muslim tibet it's the far
northwest of china and is a
sort of a turkish area where there had
been an incipient rebellion and the
authorities had refused for years to let
me go so i went anyway and they never
figured it out
after i got back and after they'd read
the stories in the new york times they
sure figured it out and they called me
in and complained vigorously
i argued that what i had done was legal
because i said i had gone as a tourist
and once i was there i decided that this
was very interesting and that therefore
i wanted to write about it and so i said
well it wasn't a reporting trip it was a
trip as a tourist
uh which by my definition was legal they
didn't see it that way and did i
gather that you've been to all 30
provinces right how about you
oh not as many but i
well at 18 19 i don't remember how often
did you travel together never almost
never never never one time we did travel
to the uh to the seaside resort of
baidaija uh that was because i found a
political story to write and he found a
travel story trying about him but that
was about it
but mainly the problem was that one of
us was always on the deng xiaoping death
watch in beijing you know we were sent
to beijing to cover the you know the
post dung china and we kept waiting for
him to die we didn't want to be both
caught out in the provinces when he did
die
deng xiaoping is
who is he
you want to know what his only formal
title is
he is the honorary chairman of the
bridge association cards
so it really shouldn't matter what
happens to the honorary chairman of the
bridge association right you call him an
emperor he is okay of course he is the
emperor of china and an emperor
in china rules until he dies so
essentially
when dung dies
that i think it will have far-reaching
change for china
we may not see it immediately for
instance if he dies monday we may not
see anything on thursday in the same way
that brezhnev's death
laid the groundwork for some remarkable
change in the soviet union uh it wasn't
immediate but uh we saw we saw what
happened evolved
how old is he in this picture that we
just saw
uh that is in 1990 so he was 86. he's 90
this year you went to his hometown i
went to his hometown uh it was the
a very interesting trip uh
he has never been back
he left when he was about 16 years old
and never turned back
never been to his parents grave never
been to his parents grave which is very
unusual in china because there's a
certain holiday a certain part of the
year where they specifically go to the
graves of their ancestors and sweep the
graves what does that say about him
what i what i think it says is that his
relationship with his family uh which
was basically a middle-class family of
the local the local landlords uh it was
a very tenuous one he i think was partly
embarrassed by the fact that he came
from a nice fairly wealthy background
and here he was a revolutionary a
communist and it was very must have been
very difficult for him to reconcile that
and
he probably was very very busy
what are you all doing now
we're studying japanese now uh the new
york times is going to send us to tokyo
to be correspondents there also as a
couple beginning
the beginning of next year how often
does the new york times allow couples to
do this
um
it's becoming more common there there
are now a few couples there's also a
couple in moscow for example
and
and there have been a few here and there
and how did you get to
report how did how did you get to the
new york times after you've been to wall
street journal oh i got married
basically i was um i had uh had
internships throughout the country and
then i went to hong kong but um i got
married and then nick was sent to
beijing and i started stringing for the
new york times and then just strung my
way onto the times
at some point you said that a rosenthal
told you to forget everything you'd ever
read or heard about china before and he
used to be the executive of the new york
times
what was the point
the point was not to be intimidated by
the fact that everybody else had been
writing about china for years and knew a
lot about it he just had to go there and
you know see what you see and smell what
you smell and just write about that
write about that tableau out there
and i think it was great advice when you
went back to your home where your
ancestors were from what did you see
i mean talk about it in terms of what we
have in our lives here in this country i
see
well uh
the village that i saw in my father's
village is is very very
backward even though it's in the
southern part of china i was just
devastated how poor the huts were they
were made out of
brick and stones put together and
sometimes they were painted yellow or or
gray we have a map here and we're going
to show that you have at the front of
the book and i want you to show me if
you can where your home is on this map
okay well
it's in right here
it says taishan
and
how did you get there
we took a uh nick was with me we took a
van uh well of course we got to
guangdong we got to uh we i'm sorry we
got first to uh macau from macau we took
uh
a taxi and we drove through the
winding winding dirt paths in guangdong
province and got to my
my the county taishan and then got to my
village what did you notice about your
wife as she was approaching her
ancestral home
uh that she was getting
i think a combination of sentimental and
uh kind of jittery about what she would
find
um
and and also i think just appalled by
the extent to which
um you know these were barefoot peasants
in every direction
and that's what you found that's what i
found it's not exactly a glorious
yes oh yeah i mean a lot of times they
were barefoot or they had sandals that
were ripped up and hadn't been having
probably 10 years old
and their clothes were shabby and i mean
i wore my sort of worse clothes i just
wore my
the rag the rags that i could find and i
still felt as though i had just walked
out of bloomingdale's uh it was um very
sad to see that because i had had so
much uh here i had grown up in the
states i was educated at private schools
i i took french and i you know shopped
at macy's and sacks and here was
my distant cousin who was 60 years old
because in china of course they the
generations they have kids at a younger
age and there he was he couldn't even
write his name when i asked him for his
address and his name he had to ask
someone else to write it down for him
where did you go to school here in the
states i went to
a school called fieldston high school in
new york city and then where and then i
went to cornell university
got a degree in what uh
intellectual history and your parents
are still in new york city they are
still in new york city what did they do
or do what do they do for a living oh
they're they're in business they have
their private businesses and why did
they come here in the first place
they were actually born well my father
was born in the states my mother was
born in canada but my grandfather came
over because at that time everybody
looked at the us as the golden land
everybody wanted to leave china and
that's the sad thing because
back then this was in the 1920s people
were leaving china because they thought
there was no opportunity there and
that's still going on uh even in china
today even though china now is just a
remarkable country going through an
enormous economic revolution people
still look at america as the land of
opportunity
you're from what part of this country
i'm a farm boy from oregon
town of yam hill oregon um population
600 and i'm four miles away from that
and where did you go to college harvard
how did you get there what was it i mean
you know from oregon to harvard's a long
way
well it helped tremendously my parents
are academics and
they teach in portland which is about an
hour away from the farm and so you know
they always have encouraged me to uh
think about you know first rate colleges
and so on and um and i think it helped
that that harvard is probably looking
for oregon farm voice to round it out
what'd you do after that
um
then i went off to oxford on a road
scholarship to study law at that time
law seemed terribly interesting then i
studied law and decided it wasn't did
you get a law degree a british law
degree yeah
can you practice on the united states no
i couldn't i there are a couple of
states where i could take the bar exam
right away i never took the bar i think
uh in nevada i could take the bar exam
and they're in new york i'd have to i
think go to some kind of committee and
request
permission
when you got to
your wife's village what was it what are
the things you're looking back on that
you remember
um i just remember thinking you know
thank god cheryl's grandfather left and
i remember also thinking that i i
wondered what had happened to the person
who had sold
cheryl's grandfather the papers that
he'd used to get to the us you know here
was somebody else who had the right to
come to the u.s
and he had sold those papers and i
wondered if his grandkids were there in
the village you know
barefoot and
and penniless and not very well educated
because perhaps their grandfather you
know wanted some cash at the time um
carpeting on the floor cars in the
village stoves in the house
refrigerators none of that none of that
none of that when i went there in 1987
there was none of that there were no
refrigerators
they cooked on a very very primitive uh
i think they had their own coal which
they would cook on but it was very
primitive and um i mean sometimes the
stones or the bricks would would
would fall out would have rotted away
and they had no money to to repair it
they had chickens they had
a pig
living right in their front yard i mean
it's not really a yard it's just in
front of the house
that was in 1987.
it's very different now
china has just
the
the the economic strides are remarkable
i went back there in in 1993 as well
back to your home i went back there what
did it change
well um
i one family there was having a
a
a celebration
because the grandchild in the family was
one month old that's a tradition in
china and so i there was a big banquet
going on and everybody from villages in
the area were coming and they were
sitting down to an eight course meal
eating what eating all sorts of things
they were eating meat also chicken
they were eating pork they were eating
all sorts of vegetables and mushrooms
would they have done that in 87
uh with
one month celebration uh they would have
celebrated it but not nearly as much as
they i mean maybe they would have had
their
few greens or vegetables because they
are they are farmers basically and so
they do uh produce their own food so
they will have a lot of vegetables and
rice and
and uh but
and
not much meat at that time but they
would have had some they would have had
some meat who's gregory gregory is our
elder son he's two and a half years old
now there's a oh well that was very
interesting because um you have another
song yeah there's another one uh jeffrey
he was just four months old
and then how did you do this in the
middle of all these this activity over
there i mean where was where was gregory
born
it was funny i mean you know you figure
that there are what uh
20 million babies born in china each
year and that it should be no problem
but we kind of figured that ours we
wanted born uh in hong kong
so he was born in hong kong and then the
chinese authorities refused to give him
a visa to get into china
well we got him a tourist visa through a
friendly travel agent with the chinese
cola the back door and got in this and
then sort of smuggled him into china on
this tourist visa
and then the foreign minister refused to
give him a residence permit the the
foreign ministry was mad at us at that
point for some articles that we'd
written about the prime minister lee
hong
and so they wouldn't give gregory his
permit uh cheryl ended up taking gregory
and his tiny baby and in swaddling
clothes to the foreign ministry
to see if he would melt their hearts you
know or poo on them at least
it didn't work neither worked they had
new hearts to meld what is it that
what is it that you did that made the
foreign ministry so mad
it was an article that nick had written
but but i think beyond that it was one
particular article about lipong and then
lipong who is he uh the prime minister
uh hardliner uh
of china
somebody who had played a major role in
the tiananmen crackdown somebody who
comes across as uh as arrogant as
unfriendly um
[Music]
extremely unpalatable politician who
misreads words every once in a while the
chinese always laugh when he trying when
he's reading a speech and
he hasn't memorized it of course but
he's got the text in front of him and he
misreads the character and they all
laugh
he's in this picture right there on the
left no that's the president jones oh
i'm sorry i got the wrong picture um how
does he become prime minister
well he benefited greatly because he was
joe and lies adopted son
and doe and lie's widow helped him out a
great deal um i mean it you know the
communists have become a little more
like
a dynasty and uh that nepotism helps
tremendously those kinds of connections
to previous leaders help a great deal
well when you wrote the article how did
you know
right away or how soon did you know that
they didn't like the article um well we
later heard that what happened was that
lee pung's office you know called up the
foreign ministry to berate them you know
how can you allow these reporters
kristoff and wu dunn to be writing these
kind of slanderous attacks
and so the foreign ministry uh called me
in to complain about that article
they
oh they broke into our office uh
they ordered the tax bureau to audit our
taxes uh the surveillance on us just
increased dramatically so you know we
would have even more people tailing us
whenever we went out it showed up pretty
quickly
speaking of your son
you wanted this your son to be delivered
in hong kong how come
i had visited a number of uh
hospitals in beijing just to check this
out i was also writing a story about the
issue and so i thought i would take an
opportunity to to look at the maternity
wards and
i
it was perfectly fine
i'm sure that i would have had no
problem but i just thought what if
what if i needed uh
sort of immediate surgery or something
like that i just didn't want to have
surgery in china okay
because i just didn't like the there was
there was a risk that i didn't want to
take and it was my first child i had not
been through this experience before i
was a jittery expectant mother i thought
hong kong was the better way to go and i
had a lot of other reporters had had
done the same thing they'd gone down to
hong kong and so there was a tradition
of of
people based in beijing going down to
hong kong to have their babies how do
you think the chinese
like your book
um
i we've had a very good response from
ordinary chinese
you know from friends
i don't know how officials will like it
i mean
we come to very optimistic conclusions
but we also go through a lot of the
communist parties dirty laundry we have
every reason to be down on china
when we were there when we just got
there kids were killed on tiananmen
square my husband was shot at my son was
effectively banned we have friends who
were thrown in prison and they're still
there but despite all that we think that
the most important thing going on in
china
today
is this economic revolution and it's
probably the most important thing going
on in the world today how can you
explain more about the economic
revolution how does it manifest itself
well one way of looking at it is that
the us has been the biggest economy in
the world in the last for the last
hundred years or so ever since we took
over from great britain and now china is
poised to take over that role to surpass
the us as the world's biggest economy
sometime in the next five decades
and you know i think that's one index of
china's growing importance you can also
look at the fact that china has the
world's biggest army uh the world's
fastest growing military budget
in sports
you know chinese women distance runners
just came out of nowhere last year to
redefine our understanding of human
potential
um
i think in a broad range of areas we're
seeing the consequences of this you know
of the 15 years of extraordinary
economic growth in china what did you
see change from 87 to 93 oh i remember
when we first went in 87 and we were
interviewing rich peasants these are
official officially chosen rich peasants
of course they would want us to see the
best they were making the average or
equivalent of 100 us dollars 200 us
dollars a month
now
in 1993
i nick actually met someone who has a
furniture business he's a peasant as
well and he has got a 10 story
building that overlooks the rice paddies
and his assets are worth
40 million us dollars and i know someone
who went to the real estate business and
in two years
has accumulated a
an empire worth a hundred million
dollars you tell the story in here of an
italian
chinese deal
right that turned on um
something familiar yeah
yeah i mean i suppose it should be kind
of a cautionary tale for american
businesses
because it you know it shows the way
things can take a strange turn this was
a italian company that was working out a
joint venture in hanan province
to make syringes
and a italian bank had arranged to make
an 18 million loan to finance the
venture
now as part of that they agreed to send
the uh chinese managing director and his
assistants to rome for the signing
and the chinese company also insisted on
sending the managing directors beautiful
assistant you know who had no clear
responsibilities but
uh the italian firm the italian bank
agreed
uh it's sort of common in china with
joint ventures that the foreign company
will pay an extra say hundred thousand
dollars in in costs to send the chinese
abroad
and then they get an extra two hundred
thousand dollars in pricing on the deal
so in this case the
italian bank paid for several people
from the chinese company to go to you
know the established italian business
centers like like venice and florence
and
they ended up in rome
and the date of the signing came for the
deal
and the chinese managing director just
refused to sign
and you know he didn't explain why and
the italians are all in a tizzy
and they keep probing and finally they
figure out what the problem is the
chinese managing director wants this
beautiful assistant of his to spend the
night with him and she's refusing
and he's blackmailing her by saying that
he's not going to sign the loan
agreement and they're not going to be
able to return to china unless she
yields
well
the italians get wind of this and
you know
they see a stalemate they could go on
for months meanwhile they're paying all
the hotel bills they began to get kind
of nervous they
they were suggesting uh that you know
maybe they could supply some
professionals for this uh this man and
uh no he was adamant uh he he just
wanted his assistant
well
it ended in the because the finally the
italians reminded the guy that
if he went ahead with the deal they were
going to give him a hundred and forty
thousand dollar cash payment uh directly
to him under the table
uh
you know nominally a consulting fee
basically he was a bribe if he went
ahead
and so he did he signed the deal they
all went back
to uh china and you know and they lived
happily ever after
not quite
uh
well
the the situation wasn't ideal it wasn't
ideal uh in the sense that obviously the
man wasn't punished and in fact he got
hundred and uh
uh eighty thousand dollars as his as his
commission as his bride
but also i think if you look a little
more closely there was some progress in
the sense that and the woman was able to
fight back in a way that she probably
would have not have been able to in
earlier years
and if the man tries to punish her if he
tries to kick her out of her job well
she can get another job at another
company
if he puts a nasty note in her personnel
file then you know personnel files don't
really matter anymore and so
you know
she she has alternatives in a way that
in maoist china she never would have
she got uh compensation uh for pain and
suffering from but from the foreign side
this is china but that's china i mean if
there's evil there's corruption there's
scandal but there is progress
at the end of your book you write about
the last dinner
would you tell us that story oh yes
after five years ever oh well for us
five years but every correspondent
before they leave
they have a dinner with the foreign
ministry in which they basically receive
a nice plaque of the great wall
and shake hands and smile a lot and take
a a a very
buoyant message about china back to the
u.s so we had our
meal at the same time there was a our
handler mr zhao and another woman who he
brought with him and we were sitting at
the table and we were all smiles and
talking about very light conversation
and he all of a sudden brings up the
fact that mr kristoff you went to uh
xinjiang province without approval
well this is where we uh got scolded for
uh nick's having gone on a tourist trip
and and writing about it uh and then he
was speaking chinese at this time yes uh
yeah we we were speaking in uh chinese
um and then he started braiding us for
how we have damaged sino-us relations
and uh was all
i just stopped eating the shrimps i just
didn't feel like you need anything and
the poor woman was embarrassed she just
looked down straight down on her table
refused to look at either of us or even
mr zhao and just
you know just kept eating as though
nothing was going on she just clearly
had tuned out
uh and he just kept going on and on and
we were just horrified uh and
we thought well let's just smile and uh
um you know swallow our food and
switch to english because we thought
that maybe if we started speaking in
english
he would feel a little bit awkward and
wouldn't be able to
criticize us so much we did that a
little bit and
then
the dinner was over and just sort of ran
away and
it was really a mistake on their part i
mean the chinese government always seems
to put its worst foot forward
they have an impeccably awful sense of
public relations here was an opportunity
to leave us with a a nice picture of
china and yet they
they ruin it by they spoil the dinner
and you know
leave a bitter taste in our mouth
i'm not sure that this is accurate but i
believe the largest number of foreign
students in america today are chinese
that's right
why i mean with the picture you paint
and the spies and all that stuff why do
they let their
their people come here and do they
follow them around the united states um
china you know however awful its human
rights situation may be is a lot less
awful than it used to be it's opening up
by the day uh it's becoming uh you know
it's it's it's not nearly as uh closed
as the eastern european countries were
in indeed you know by and large chinese
can go abroad now if they want to
uh and so you have this huge exodus of
around 50 000 chinese students coming to
the us now once there are here there are
spies and that who do keep an eye on
others who are politically active
they may get in some trouble if they go
back
but again you know the i think the
communist party is losing its ability to
either inspire people or or terrify them
you write that you were sympathetic to
the communists
uh yeah when i first arrived in china um
i had
some sympathies with the communist
revolution i mean
i think that if i had been a chinese in
the late 1940s i might well have been a
communist you know they promised
overturned corruption to
divide up the land
and it's clear that first they did a
fair amount of good you know
they raised the status of women they had
literacy campaigns all of that
what about you would you have been a
communist
uh no
no i i didn't really have any kind of
affinity for that what about the family
when you were growing up oh my parents
were
in fact my grandfather on my mother's
side
i was on the welcoming party uh
when uh for sunyat
the other side the
taiwan side so they were not communists
who took your place by the way for the
new york times
in china and can you buy the
international herald tribune in any
hotels
uh our successor is a fellow called pat
tyler and yeah you can buy the herald
tribune you can buy the hong kong papers
you can buy newsweek and time all in in
the beijing hotels
i uh wrote down the name ah chang
who was he he was a man who he's a
cantonese uh what is that and that means
that he is from the southern province of
guangdong and he lives in uh what used
to be called canton but now everybody
refers to guangzhou and let me tell you
if you live in guan gua
how close to hong kong oh that's very
close to it borders
uh on hong kong and that's where my uh
home village is so if people go to hong
kong they can get in the train or in a
car and drive right up there right right
okay
right
and uh he's a very interesting case
because uh he every time i meet him
every time i met him uh
he would be richer he would be
more
having he would have all these new
business ideas uh he
was a man who was not very
pro-democratic he really cared mostly
about
coming up making money and helping his
sisters helping his family along but
around the time of the tiananmen square
massacre after the massacre he saw his
opportunity he saw that now if he could
just claim himself a student or someone
who had supported the movement and
get overseas and claim asylum in in the
u.s then he wouldn't have to go back to
china so he bought a passport a fake
passport and that got him to the u.s
what did it cost him uh 40 000 us
dollars he had that much money then
um but when he got there he turned
himself in
and he turned himself in because he
couldn't live with he was afraid that he
would be caught with a fake passport
even though he had gotten as far as he
had where'd he go
he went through not directly to the us
he went through asia
spent some time in singapore and japan
and then back then back to the us and he
turned himself into he turned himself
into the authorities to the u.s
authorities and uh he thought that they
would be sympathetic to his cause he
said that i was a uh um i sympathized
with the students and i helped them and
you know i'm afraid that i'll be
persecuted if i go back to china
they didn't pay any attention to him
they sent him on the first they sent him
back to china and he was uh
fined a lot when he got back to the got
back to the to china and he had nothing
with him he had lost all the money that
he had invested in this in this venture
and he had to start from scratch luckily
he was not thrown in prison uh because
we know other people who have been
thrown into prison but he started from
scratch built up another restaurant
business and he was really lucky he
found a great spot and so one day
a foreign venture came up foreign
investors came up to him and said we
want this spartan we'll pay you another
forty thousand dollars we'll pay you
forty thousand dollars for the spot he
took it
now he's uh running all sorts of
businesses now he's uh going into the
pharmaceutical business
uh he's smuggling dogs in from uh into
china which in china
it's rather unusual because chinese are
used to eating dog not having them as
pets he's smoking them into china as
pets
and he says you know i'm doing something
good for china i'm trying to i'm trying
to tell chinese people that
dogs are nice things as pets not as food
speaking of eating dogs
you have a whole
section on cannibalism eating humans
what's that about
um that i suppose is a reminder that you
know however awful things are they used
to be a lot more awful in the cultural
revolution when china was all falling
apart
in guangxi which is in the south of
china in the far south
there were
several counties where
brutality was as great as anywhere
and we got a hold of some documents
these are secret communist party
documents that a chinese writer had
given us
and they outlined
just extraordinary brutality the where
perhaps the biggest uh incident of
cannibalism modern times but it wasn't
you know because of famine or some sort
of psychopathic murderer this was
politics
what would happen is the red guards the
you know maos red guards who were
leading the cultural revolution would
be struggling against some kind of
landlord or somebody they would call a
counter-revolutionary they would beat
him to death and then they would have
the crowd
eat his flesh as a way of proving their
hatred for this kind of person
and so you had
some students you know roasted their
principal in the school yard and all the
students would have to eat it to sort of
show their their hatred for these people
uh in one case the first student to take
some flesh from the principal's body was
the boyfriend of the principal's
daughter because he wanted to show that
that he hated that man that he had no
affection for the family
um you had
what year was the was this during the
great leap forward no this was mostly in
1968 in the cultural revolution what was
the great leap forward that was in 1958
and that's where you read a lot about
the famine
yeah that was the worst famine in world
history now it provoked the worst famine
in world history 30 million people died
why
now what caused the famine yeah it was a
combination of a lot of factors part of
it was that china had just been
collectivizing its countryside and uh it
had been paying attention to all these
kinds of grand projects to
for example to have steel mills all
throughout the countryside
peasants were ordered to you know throw
in their metal implements into these
backyard steel furnaces
and
they so they were spending all their
times on these things producing
worthless steel
losing their implements they started
all kinds of you know grand projects to
build aqueducts build dams this kind of
thing and then elected the countryside
and then finally mao
kind of deceived himself i mean he he
kept telling people that if they just
tried hard enough they could increase
grain output you know by a hundred
percent or more and so all the local
officials started and they saw that if
they didn't report these kinds of
outrageous figures then they would be in
trouble so they began reporting to the
center oh yeah that our county's grain
output rose you know whatever 100
percent and so the center began
demanding more grain from the localities
and there wasn't enough to feed the
peasants and
you know 30 million people died you
write about it is it edgar snow
who wrote for look magazine who told his
audience years ago back in those days
that there was no such thing as a famine
that was one of the scariest things for
us as china watchers that you know at
that time you had a whole legion of
china watchers travel throughout the
country and edgar snow was you know
the most prominent of them
and uh they interviewed people they
traveled around in some cases for months
and they concluded that the one thing
they could be sure of was that there was
no famine going on
and
obviously in retrospect they were
hoodwinked and cheryl and i you know we
really began to wonder about our own
ability 30 years later to really know
what was happening especially in the
countryside
and you know there were times when we
really thought that uh
when we were surprised by how much could
happen out there we had no clue about
one of the things that we were most
proud of the stories that we were most
proud of was about was about the family
planning clampdown that took place it
began in 1991 and it led to the forced
sterilization of millions of women
basically there's a you know there's a
one-child policy in china people are
allowed based only one and sometimes two
and depending upon the area remote if
it's very remote three uh children but
because china
chinese families especially in the
countryside they favor boys over girls
and so they if they only are allowed one
or two kids they want it to be a boy
lineage is passed down through them
through males and
daughters marry outside of the family so
they want boys so the result is
that every year 1.7 million baby girls
go missing
some of them are unreported some of them
are
the midwife takes the head of the
newborn baby and dunks it into a bucket
of water
a lot are
aborted done in even before they are
born because of the new machine that is
probably the most remarkable in china
having the most pervasive influence and
that's the ultrasound museum
machine
expected mothers go to the doctors and
they're not supposed to learn the sex of
the fetus but if they pay a bribe to the
doctor the doctor will tell them and if
it's a girl they usually abort it
and
then after they've had maybe one or two
kids there the woman is forced to go
through a sterilization uh so we learned
about this we wrote about this and we
were very proud of it we learned about
it two years after the clan ban had had
begun
the foreign community learned about it
two years after it had begun and this no
policy um
probably in in the world affected so
many people so intimately as this family
planning clampdown
you say that world bank figures show
that by the year 2025 that
the population will go from 1.2
billion to 1.6 billion
this country will have 307 million in it
and japan will only grow by 2 million at
127 million what do those figures tell
you
well they underscore that china does
have a genuine population problem i mean
every year china
adds to its population uh 16 million
people which is equivalent to the entire
population of australia
but
you know still i
mean again i started off fairly
sympathetic to china's population policy
and more i went on the more i thought it
was uh just tremendously brutal and not
worth it
chapter 10
i'll show this picture because you have
it in your book uh you start off this
with an excerpt
or rather how would you describe it
startling one startling excerpt from a
book why
because that just shows how far china
has come um people think still have this
image of the chinese as as prudish
people who uh who don't like to talk
about uh anything that
touches on sex but of course you know
the population is growing enormously so
it does exist in china uh and
it exists in the literature now uh this
one a book that was written by an author
who actually has a fairly good
reputation for writing good fiction uh
he decided he wrote this book called
wasted capital and it's about the
decadence it's about the
the lewd lives of several individuals
and he just describes for instance a
a woman dies
masturbating with corn cobs i mean it's
just some of the images are just
outrageous
and it did very well in china in the
last few uh weeks and months that we
were there it was a
hot seller and authorities tried to ban
it several times finally they did ban it
but there were still a lot of copies
that had already gotten out your first
book
yes what do you think of the process
um it was a wonderful one uh you know we
really enjoyed
the i mean really every part of it
pictures the editing
cover everything
what do you think of it
i really like it
i think it's i think it was just a
wonderful process here's your dedication
was this a hard choice
um
no um i mean our parents uh
had just been so supportive the whole
way through we wanted to recognize them
who is the what's the name on the bottom
she's my sister
and why is she the one that's in hong
kong
no no
um
obviously not because she was she died
in 1983. she was on the kl flight the kl
double 007 unfortunately
where was she going she was going to
hong kong
and how old was she at the time she was
21.
uh you did reference though in the book
that you have a sister in hong kong how
many how many children in the family
four
what about hong kong what did you learn
about 1997 when it reverts to control of
the chinese
um
the
uh we love hong kong so much and we have
great hopes for it but you know the
standard argument about why the chinese
aren't going to hurt it is you know they
don't want to kill the goose that lays
the golden egg and i remember when chris
patton he was the
british
the briton who was who went there as to
be governor of hong kong when he arrived
the hong kong officials were telling him
you know you can relax we're not going
to hurt hong kong you know we don't want
to kill the ghost lays the golden egg
and his reply was the only reason that
expression came into existence is
because history is littered with the
carcasses of dead geese
which is a useful reminder
still
my bet is that it's going to despite
some trouble some troubles i
still do pretty well i mean already it's
striking that hong kong is really in
many ways taking over southern china
rather than the other way around
you can get hong kong radio in in the
southern part of china you can get hong
kong radio you can watch hong kong
television you can see hong kong movies
who's taking over who is really a
question will they be able to stop the
the
satellite television in china
probably not they're you know
they can make announcements they can
crack down in one particular city one
particular neighborhood but they're
really losing their ability to control
things more broadly information
revolution has come to china how does
someone get a satellite dish oh well you
can go to a store and buy it uh then
they put down they put they enforce this
they tried to enforce this new
regulation where you couldn't buy
satellite dishes but you could still get
them
you uh quote alex de tocqueville you
bring up james madison in this book
what's the and you talk about the civil
society what's the point
the point is that china right now
although it doesn't have jeffersonian
democracy uh there is a movement there
there is progress uh nick talked about
cannibalism there is no longer that kind
of cannibalism there but people are
taking getting a larger stake in the
system we have people now who
are
interested in in you know in listening
to talk radio i mean talking radio is
something from the from the west it's uh
through talk radio
people are discussing problems of
romance they're talking about the
garbage collection the filthy garbage
that's all over the street why doesn't
someone clean up they're complaining
delicately about officials
about their local officials people who
have done them wrong there is a
new law administrative law that allows
people to sue government bureaucracies
tiny tiny little changes but they are
steps toward a more freer a more richer
society
next stop japan why do you want to do
that
we're captivated by the changes taking
place in asia and we think that that
will be another vantage point to view
this from and also another way of
looking at the various debates in this
country whether it's healthcare or crime
i think that japan will offer some
interesting and illuminating lessons for
us you're learning japanese yes
is it hard
yes
how are you how are you being taught
where uh
right now we're mostly on the farm in
oregon and we're we have teachers coming
to the farm and so every day five hours
a day we just
go through the japanese lessons
wendy report
for your for in japan oh at the end of
the year
and what are you looking forward to
what's the first thing you want to go
find out about
um
i suppose crime uh
i mean i'm really curious about
what it is about japan that's
responsible for its very low crime rates
and is that the way the police are
organized or the you know the gun
control i think that's going to be
interesting how do you think you'll be
received in japan versus how you've been
received in the united states over you
know being a chinese asian oh i think
it'll be very interesting um the status
of women of in in japan of course is is
even worse than it is in china and in
china it's still uh pretty bad i mean
you know in china for thousands of years
women have been thought of as nothing
more than walking wombs and even my
grandmother she had her feet bound and
always walked
well very awkwardly
and you would have thought that after 10
years of reform 15 years of reform in
china that the status of women would
have risen dramatically but in many ways
it hasn't you know you have the rise of
the market and with the rise of the
market has come sinister industries like
for instance you have a trade in copper
you have a trade in toys and clothes but
you also have a trade in women you have
the trade in wives business men and
women they go to
villages in the countryside and they
recruit these uneducated peasant women
with the promise of better jobs and
higher pay and they transport them to
other areas remote areas of the country
where they don't know the local dialect
and in china if you don't speak the
local dialect you basically cannot
communicate and they sell them to
uncouth peasants and i know of one story
where a woman she tried to escape and
the peasant blinded her he gouged out
her eyes
i mean that kind of stuff goes on in
china we're out of time
this is the cover of the book
a struggle for the soul of a rising
power china wakes authors nicholas
christoph and his wife cheryl
wudon thank you very much for joining us
thank you thank you
nicholas d kristoff and cheryl wooden
husband and wife were awarded the
pulitzer prize in 1990 for their
reporting on the tiananmen democracy
movement in china and its suppression
china wakes us published by vintage
books and in print of random house visit
randomhouse.com for more information